i've made a mistake in my life and that  is it it's contrary to what i teach  i've not been great in my life at being  present  i've not been great at it i think a lot  of achievers struggle with this and i go  in and out of this mode where if i was  in the was at the pool yesterday with my  kids  and i'm looking at him and max is going  to college this year  my daughter's like a young woman now you  know and  i wish when they were a little younger  that those moments when we were in the  pool when they were younger i was just  with them i'm not thinking about work  and thinking about protecting them and  thinking about saving for college and  being in the moment and enjoying now  right like really enjoying now and the  moments i'm the most effective the most  blissful the most joyful spreading it is  what i'm the most present